this is Warren Buffett the value
investor worth 67 billion with the Halo
the size of Saturn's rings everyone is
itching to be pulled into his orbit and
we mean everyone especially when it
comes to headline writers who love to
anoint people and use his name like it's
a mad lib blank is the Warren Buffett of
blank but are all these Buffett as
characters really worthy do they have
anything in common with him Carlos Slim
aka the Warren Buffett of Mexico whom
depending on the day is richer than
Buffett give or take a couple of hundred
million dollars of course the irony here
no one calls Buffett the slim of America
aliko dangote the Warren Buffett of
Africa is the richest guy on the African
continent Worth 22 billion dollars he
owns various entities including a food
and beverage company Buffett owns
ketchup maker Heinz LeBron James the
mega athlete it's been asked in
countless articles if he is the next
worm Buffett both became millionaires in
their 20s and we hear Buffett is a fan
of LeBron
the buffet of Warren Buffett
associations to choose from is vast Mark
Zuckerberg is the Warren Buffett of
Technology the Warren Buffett of wine
Robert Parker the movie industry Woody
Allen there's even a Warren Buffett of
cricket Sachin Tendulkar and of bass
fishing Greg Myerson who studies his
prey the way Buffett studies markets
with all these fill in the blank buffets
I'm starting to think that Suzanne
Wooley the Warren Buffett of financial
journalism sounds pretty good now